[Aplausos]
el senado le dijo sí a la versión
definitiva de la Reforma de pensiones
ahora el controvertido proyecto de
Emmanuel macron debe superar la última
etapa en la asamblea nacional los votos
de la derecha y el centro fueron los que
dieron el éxito en la cámara alta con
193 a favor y 114 en contra mientras que
casi por unanimidad los sindicatos de
trabajadores rechazaron el proyecto de
ley desde el minuto cero y han salido
las calles desde mediados de enero en
multitudinarias protestas no queremos
Elevar la edad de jubilación a 64 años
porque 64 años significa penalizar a los
que han trabajado mucho tiempo por lo
tanto a los que tienen trabajos más
difíciles y los que reciben los salarios
más bajos
el texto de la comisión parlamentaria
mixta propone una reforma que garantice
el futuro de nuestro sistema de
pensiones somos conscientes de que este
texto marca un precedente Y que debe ir
acompañado de cambios profundos en la
consideración de los empleados más
antiguos
Emmanuel ma la primera ministra
Elizabeth born esperan tener el
resultado de los legisladores y poder
cantar Victoria sin necesidad de activar
el artículo 49.3 una medida que le
permite al gobierno suspender el debate
parlamentario sin embargo el suspenso
permanece Pues el futuro del proyecto
está sobre todo en manos de la asamblea
nacional donde los asambleístas de
derecha que a diferencia del senado
están divididos y son más escépticos a
la reforma el proyecto propone aumentar
la edad de jubilación de los 62 a los 64
años para el 2030 que algunas categorías
específicas puedan jubilarse antes
trabajar un mínimo de 43 años para
obtener una pensión completa desde 2027
otorgar una jubilación anticipada para
aquellos que empezaron a trabajar antes
de los 20 años y que la edad mínima para
pensionarse se incremente gradualmente
en tres meses cada año el presidente ha
dicho que el proyecto es indispensable
para el funcionamiento del sistema
pensional Pues de no implementarse ha
advertido que se llegará a un déficit de
13.500 millones de euros